(faucet water running)
(glass slams on table)
(purse smacks on bar stool)
(female claps hands)
- Hello.
I'm wondering if I could
trouble you for a drink.
I should have a tab open
under the name Annette Bening.
Craving something
with a little kick.
Do you do these?
Jalapeño margarita.
- Yeah.
- Salt on the rim.
Little sprinkle of cayenne?
Do you do fresh lime?
- Actually, yeah.
- Bottled lime?
Roses? I'm cool with anything.
But, I just should know
'cause they're gonna
pumping extra sugar
into those bottled lime juices,
which you know is pretty gross.
You know, can you
believe that actually?
(purse slams onto
another bar stool)
The extra sugar?
I mean what's this FDA doing,
now that I'm thinking about it?
Do you put red chile
flake in the margarita?
It's dangerous.
You can ask Billy Crudup.
The sweetest, dearest
mouse you ever did meet.
He saw me nearly
choke to death
at the 20th Century
(mumbles) wrap party.
Got lodged.
My uvula, my
throat. Right there.
Hacking, all week.
Couldn't smoke. Just
that deep, the guttural,
- God.
- that (gags).
Can I vape in here?
This isn't an airport,
I'm gonna vape.
- I'm sorry I
actually need to, uh.
- (gasps) Oh my god.
(sucks on vaporizer)
I (coughs) just remembered,
I have a voiceover
spot this week.
Lets just cut all
spice all together.
And while we're here,
I must insist we use
George's tequila.
- I do not know who that is.
- George Clooney.
He's a dear friend. And the
tequila really is the best.
And I wouldn't say that.
That is not who I am.
Actually, he's the one who
taught me the difference
between gold and silver tequila.
And, um, you're gonna kill me.
You're going to kill me.
You will murder me.
'Cause you know what?
After all I've said and done.
What I really want
Is.
A.
Mojito.
- That's what you want?
- Yup.
- Okay.
Yeah. And a hotdog, too.
If you have it.
Please.
(sucks on vaporizer loudly)
- I.
- That's really good.
Channing Tatum.